how about a pizza party that's back to
your silly goose time that's what I was
like yeah oh that's time dude you should
do a pizza party but just buy one pizza
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we need to talk about this
road to 2 million
if we get there
YouTube Subs I'm talking if we get to 2
million what are we gonna do to
celebrate we all look at Bart the fans
have like so many different suggestions
but I want to know without knowing any
of those what would you feel like doing
well one of the things we're talking
about in the chat that I thought was
pretty cool was the whole meet and Miss
idea
he wanted to do a mobile meet and greet
I wanted to do a meet and greet where
like we're on a double decker bus and
then we're like we'll meet you guys here
at this time right and then so all the
fans show up and then we show up on
double decker bus and then I'm like all
right try to catch us and then we just
slowly drive away that's like the uh
parades when you win the championship
you know like the Warriors driving
through San Francisco Steph Curry's just
like this Hammer drunk Clay Thompson's
[ __ ] tripping on him with the [ __ ]
trophy you know there's one player with
his shirt off that'll be Bart yeah you
want a parade
a silly goose time
silly goose time what let me let me uh
tell you some suggestions that people
actually want right it's like these are
terrible ideas I'm gonna get to them let
me
let me think of these
I think uh some people wanted uh JK to
do a classic like JK party and play
Mafia and do all the games and [ __ ] oh
cool relive the past that's wholesome
that's very important of course that's
cool but it's like that's affordable
yeah
more than the double decker bust
double decker bus I like Adventures so
like let's say we like I don't know
Mafia in the woods yeah
right and then we're in the middle of
the ocean and then we let people know
what the GPS coordinates are and they
get to rent jet skis and then meet us
over there so that sounds scary that
sounds like a dumb good idea jet skis
it's still a meat and Miss but on the
water
everybody ready jet skis meet us here at
these coordinates as we bounce bone out
as we fly over people don't even know
how to read coordinates I think it's an
overestimation on how many people have
jet skis but that's just you just rent
them for like 20 bucks an hour or
something right no way it's 20 bucks
that's not 20.
inflation
at the beach they're like 60 70 I think
at the beach because it's more
maintenance and on a lake they're
cheaper but on the beach they're they're
more we're gonna go lake Lake Mead then
what's our uh YouTube analytics for
regional subscribers like what areas
what countries are like the highest
subscribe probably past the US what if
it was Haiti Oh you mean the second to
us yeah second to us and stuff like that
am I invited on this [ __ ] yeah I know
are you invited yeah let's just leave
now let's just do our own thing back
here we need you guys to like help us
think because we're too [ __ ] close to
like figure it out I like work I think
that's nice for saying no you're not
necessarily invited but we need people
thank you I think you go down the list
of analytics where Anthony's going here
and you choose like the city that's
biggest on the list not the smallest in
the world right keep going no you know
what I mean like because Paris is going
to be top five you don't go to Paris but
if like there's some random one that
sneaks into the top 20 go there and
throw a party like Lake Paris yeah yeah
all right
so U.S is roughly 55 of the viewership
second to that's Canada
and then after that's UK
Canada I'm like wait so it's only the
people that understand English probably
uh most of the US is in California too
okay yeah is there like a cool city in
in the U.S you know a little sneaky boss
Summerlin very cool to get a boat in the
UK in England and then have them have
people the the British people meet you
in the channel the channel or on the
teams that can work that'd be nice I
don't think he's decided about it how
about a pizza party that's back to your
silly goose time that's what I was like
yeah I'm speaking Bart now
one of these OG San Gabriel yeah all
Park yeah and we'll just buy a stack of
Costco pizza nice pizza party yeah oh
that's time dude you should do a pizza
party but just buy one pizza
[Laughter]
we just come in here when we hit two
Milli just everybody bringing like a
weapon of choice and we just destroy and
demolish what we can and rebuild
um just rip [ __ ] off the walls [ __ ]
talk okay
it's just like a spear who the [ __ ]
comes with a spear that'd be so
inefficient
the arcade
you like games why in the [ __ ] would you
go for the one thing that hasn't even
been here that long can I bet a dollar
can I just want a dollar if someone's
gonna get stabbed oh probably we'll take
that bed I'm [ __ ] ripping Bart's
painting off no no no no no no no no I'm
gonna do that just spear right through
the [ __ ] eyes yeah it took me like
four hours did you think about it for a
long time
I've been dreaming about it since it was
like three it's like one goes like this
one goes like that I was trying to make
the color smooth and I couldn't
I think smooth is the exact opposite
word I would use for that yeah so it
goes India then Australia are the last
two you got to go to India India would
[ __ ] be gangster dude go to India you
got to go to India let's go film a
couple episodes yeah we create that no I
don't want to be invited
[ __ ] down I heard a sketch I heard it
smells like [ __ ] oh you get used to it
number one number two depends where you
go right right I guarantee though
[ __ ] our Indian fans will pull up I
can show you a place two blocks here
that smells like [ __ ]
it's on two blocks that's pretty good I
mean all of Chinatown smells like [ __ ]
over here don't matter dude the food
will be good the fans will be great
that's all that matters it is it is
gonna be [ __ ] bad we do a pizza
partying in Mumbai and have what by
Wednesday Curry Pizza bring some Costco
what else you know what I mean bring
Costco Kirkland Signature to India yeah
my boy got the teas okay so so obviously
we're not going there because Bart
doesn't like the smell I've got to go to
smelly places Mr stinky tofu that's
close enough
yeah so what other things could we do at
two mil
in terms of content yes yeah what did
some fans say uh well the party is one
uh they want all some fans want to bring
back old JK and then have some thing
where we compete against old JK versus
new JK with weapons this is this is
where they need to start going to fan
fiction where they start writing it
because I think the fans also need to be
practical
about what we're gonna is that
impractical to bring back just a bunch
of people that might have like ever so
slight animosity towards us
[Laughter]
yeah that's actually a great idea I love
being uncomfortable for viewership yeah
but if we have one task like rebuild the
office or destroy the office maybe it's
cathartic for them too oh that's true
yeah common enemy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and Bartell we're like waiting to fix it
we're like hurry up guys come on
you could feed them by one pizza
stupid
what do you guys celebrate normally like
I don't celebrate birthdays no just I
mean like as a human even you know let
me show you this thing we don't have
much to celebrate this guy's busting a
joke no I mean in your lives because
like some people celebrate you know like
oh my God yeah oh my God it's our sixth
month you got a car wash I'm so proud of
you [ __ ] like that this is how bad we
are at celebrating pop that right now
then so we got this bottle of crisp so
we had a uh an intern
didn't wasn't the the what is the term
the sharpest tool in the shed he's
stupid okay she's stupid yeah and then
we needed a bottle of crystal for a
shoot and then
um
I don't know why this is during the time
where we don't have very many budgets
she spent like 300 on this
yes real Christa yeah we're like oh is
that how much that is buy it you never
watch the Jay-Z music yeah we could have
did something else but she bought it and
we only had maybe 500 bucks in the bank
account or something so it was a good
deal we got stuck with this and then
we're like you know what when we hit I
think a million subscribers or something
we're gonna pop it
and this is back in 2004 as you can see
I don't know if champagne's will last
very long it doesn't last over a year
maybe maybe two so it gets better it
might be rotten and we've never popped
it because I think once we hit that
marker we didn't even care though
they're probably no bubbles you didn't
care it'll taste it'll taste like shame
but there'll be no bugs like me and Joe
never really celebrated birthdays or you
know just even personal celebrations so
why the [ __ ] are we shooting this video
I think because you guys are here
Angel our Asperger robots oh okay so
we're humanizing the channel a little
yeah you guys do have Asperger's oh no
we do so you need us
and one pizza please dude the dancers
are saving the channel dude honestly
don't say that Steve's not gonna like it
Steve said it the other day he did
he did say that [ __ ]
yeah he goes he goes [ __ ] the dancers
are saving the channel he's in like that
no way he didn't say that all right you
know what we're gonna do we're just
gonna go on JK live right now and IG and
they're gonna tell us right now anybody
give the suggestions on how you think we
should celebrate 2 million followers we
just have every guest that came in in
the last two years all at one time
but just let them know no pay are we
really on track to getting there because
we've been going down and then we
started coming back up this year which
is really cool thank you guys
and are we on track to catch to go to
get in there yeah okay we're at 1.88
right now wow and it's gone up about 10
to 20K per day in the last uh five days
wow you guys are awesome it's the Yankee
Yak huh yeah The Tick Tock be bumping
it's a tick tock and the YouTube shorts
yeah so we need to figure out what we're
gonna do celebrate because everyone's
expecting something really cool oh
another another idea that someone had
suggested was uh they wanted to do
something where we we picked our
favorite guests that we've had on the
show since New Era and we make them do
it episode but none of us are here it's
just each if I don't get invited I'm
taking that first it's like six of the
best guests that we've ever had yeah and
then their show is so much better that
they're like hey can we just keep them
these guests are dope yeah I'm not down
for this one because I'm a little
insecure okay
it finally achieves perfect diversity
I'm on bar space oh we're being a little
overzealous should we do this video at
like 1.99 or something like that
you know because we're about to hit a
recession people might start canceling
their YouTube accounts I don't know yeah
YouTube Alex
[Laughter]
a subscription and cutbacks yeah man
it's it's interesting because I think we
could do something pretty fun audio's
not working they're saying oh wow thank
you Ken
wow so we need to figure it out two
million what do we do I saw some of the
comments say that they want uh they want
like Bart and Joe and them to like do a
dance routine oh no I saw that too I
ignored those because I don't
that's because you're
you're because of dancing in life no are
you talking about you so you have like a
big enough meet and greet or something
and then oh [ __ ] come up to you
and [ __ ] them yeah I don't think we're
that big but if you got those fears I
feel you I think so there's some
SoundCloud rapper I don't know how big
he is or his name but uh so one of my
best friends and my roommate uh owns a
security company they haven't come they
have Dan come Glock up okay
it's a charity event to be fair I think
people in the rap game though that's
different that's a little bit but you
guys do say some crazy [ __ ] yeah I would
feel comfortable Dan would do it Dan
would do it for free
that's cool let's have him around yeah
we need some security for all like three
people on jet skis that show up in the
middle of the ocean
[Laughter]
[Music]
I guess we're not really good at coming
up with ideas let's go skydiving guys oh
do you want to go Sky to jump out of the
plane I did is this scary you'll be fine
I think I'm too heavy what yeah you too
swole no you could be what is it what's
the total I thought it was 220. you
might be 40 because you always have to
be a tandem yeah that's true yeah ain't
nobody trying to hold on to those fat
asses how much are you got 220 more for
the sake of jumping on an airplane I am
give me a week I'll be 222. yeah you
gotta you gotta cut weight for this yeah
I got a big old dumpy you'll be pushing
into the guy behind me yeah it's gonna
be uncomfortable for all of us he's
going to be boned up dude for sure just
brick fall
sounds like for the most part people
just want something to do with like to
see more people together in one room
that we've had over time so what if we
do like a what if we do like a nine-man
thing we get like
because last time the fans really liked
when we had like an extra person at each
table yeah that's one of the most
favorite things is the nine-man chaos
yeah but then we we fill it up with you
know good friends of the show and we
just be but that's a dope ass idea yeah
do you guys want more of a live thing or
just more content thing
you know to be fair I think if as a fan
though as well when you're talking about
something like 2 million you're talking
about not like a moment like just just
January if we hit it you're talking
about like since the beginning that you
started to get there you're talking
about some of the fans that are there
are people that were in the the 10 000
subscribers so I might be really
interested like oh this is a huge
Landmark can I see uh like the uncles
come back yeah
oh not necessarily go produce a [ __ ]
skit like dedicated to me but like you
know maybe we get some elgos out and we
like have a little party I would love to
see some old cast members you know what
I mean that were [ __ ] safe animosity
members the ones that still love us type
[ __ ] you know Julia just remember I
didn't do [ __ ] you know I was a nice guy
to everybody just saying that on record
but um OTR
um but realistically you know I'm
thinking about like the history of JK
and the things that I fell in love with
and being able to see a little bit of
that if it's not here today in the
current you know what I'm saying I
thought that would be cool if we did
some sort of like that's what I was
thinking maybe live like an auditorium
type setting and then maybe we can have
some of the like cut up uh
uh the more condensed content that we've
been having we could screen and watch it
live and laugh together and then if we
can have a panel of all the people and
we can like have a big one you might be
able to record live like that yeah that
might be you could literally do this at
an auditorium yeah yeah that might be
kind of cool oh dang we can't edit [ __ ]
out though
I don't never say anything that I don't
mean
[Laughter]
they want us to throw a wet fish at
Anthony
why I love that guy who's that you
remember when you were saying like do
you guys get afraid of getting stuck
this is how it [ __ ] starts guys it
starts with a wet fish next thing you
know it's a [ __ ] knife you know what
I mean you better watch out yeah I like
that guy somebody said do a campfire uh
episode that's kind of cute like we're
just like it's just us around a campfire
doing the same thing that's kind of
wholesome a cat a camping episode
oh [ __ ]
that's a cool idea
or they're saying do it but make it live
so people can stream it that's kind of
interesting yeah even a live episode
that's pretty cool oh yeah it doesn't
have to be a live event but I think a
lot of aren't all fish wet that's like
you still love that yeah
that's actually a good idea like a live
one yeah you just go live on the tubes
yeah that might be a good idea that's
pretty cool it's a wild show with a
bunch of [ __ ] peeps in there why
don't you guys go paintballing
with like like select fans
that want to shoot us in the face yeah
yeah
I'm sending that one out for sure we're
like these before just make sure they
don't freeze the paintballs yeah you
know I don't know if that sounds that
fun
park gets his eyes are real small that
means he's skeptical dude you can take
prisoners you know it could be that kind
of paintball they said go to Hawaii hey
that's pretty cool yeah and then just
what just like I'm here
you guys should go to Hawaii eat some
Spanish and that's how you celebrate
okay and then wash it down with some
matcha Joe's maybe I'm also trying to
kill two birds one stone but maybe we
could like auction off some of this [ __ ]
that we need to get rid of here to like
fans and maybe half of it goes to
charity but half of it really goes to
rent and the rest of our pay cut you
know what I mean but you know what I'm
saying we got to get rid of some [ __ ]
here anyway we got liquidase recession
there's a bunch of really really cool
paraphernalia that belongs to expired
champagne maybe no no bubbles that's
dope it's got a story behind it you know
what I'm saying
actually you know what you and Joe
should sign it and just keep it as like
a Memento because opening is going to be
pointless yeah right you should just
sign it or selling it for 50 bucks it's
gonna have a point
it's already because the bubbles are
gone so you care I love my champagne you
can drink it it'll be flat you know
it'll be flat flat Crystal the amount of
[ __ ] texture in here that should just
be sold oh yeah I'm just you guys can
find memory sign memory cards like
digital cards
that would be pretty cool if when when
we redo like uh let's say you hit the
two million Mark then you we have to
redo the place but in doing so we do
auction or give away certain key like
things that are sitting around do yeah
if you guys have you know those digital
clocks you have a whole bunch of them
you you and Joe should take a topless
photo and hide it in one of them and
then like sign all of them and then have
people auction them you know like
auction them buy them and then one lucky
fan will get a topless photo of you and
Joe whoa what about a JK calendar just
just let you know Bart's topless in
almost every [ __ ] shoot so uh
so is Joe sometimes Joe's more topless
than I am really his nips are always out
that guy's wearing the [ __ ] fur coat
with no shirt underneath you're wearing
nothing with no shirt no I hook up with
shirt on
different photos on each card because
that's what K-pop CDs do they have like
daily Unique Images on in each package
yeah
it could be like a song you guys wrote a
song and sing this like make a music
video on one album full of Music see
it's perfect it'll be hidden in each
card now we released it but I don't know
if we did a good job promoting it's
called Uh special feelings have you
heard of the tracks from there no it
sounds like a banger though
it's crazy I went to the club they
didn't play it
people are asking for a skit oh wow what
are the likelihood of doing another skip
are you so sick of skits at this point
you mean like yeah like that I love
shooting skits with like throwback
elements from like old [ __ ] I just gotta
know like my tattoos
maybe oh you're gonna cry
let's comment that I like the topless I
like the skits too it's just the uh
it's like one of those things there's so
much pressure on the thing yeah that
skin has to be perfect or else I'm not
gonna feel happy with it and I know just
with the constraints it's not going to
be it would be like a bad YouTube Rewind
potentially yeah yeah you know the best
way the best way to alleviate the best
way to leave you that pressure is have
uh people you trust someone else write
it and you guys don't write it that way
if it doesn't work out you're like well
you know what I'm sorry but I didn't
write it yeah you just blame it on
Stephen that's the best way on your two
Milli back to the skits thing that all
the fans have been waiting for forever
you're just like oh man it wasn't good
but he wrote it yeah sorry guys once we
wrote that one so who wrote it that's
why it's all sad and [ __ ] romantic
and [ __ ] hey I do I do kind of like the
idea of live taping though a lot of
people are agreeing with that campfire
thing maybe you do the campfire thing
combined with the life
are you doing a Parks type deal a little
outdoorsy just don't play guitar you
guys can sing songs okay oh we got some
guitars yeah we could do that like a
special episode where it's kind of this
just this but like a little bit
heightened yeah it'd be kind of cool
that seems appropriate okay or we just
get [ __ ] drunk and just keep on
shooting the next day like it wasn't a
big deal and everything goes all [ __ ]
normal and thanks anyways yeah but then
we can't get the deposit back with the
double decker oh [ __ ] yeah we'll party
we'll see you guys at 2 million in the
middle of the ocean meet and leave
what'd you call it me Miss he's called
me because not everybody's gonna get it
thank you